so we watched the first half of the Xbox
game showcase earlier today now we are
going to catch up on the Starfield
Direct
I
I think I have really high expectations
I am a little bit scared about the whole
thousand planets thing and what that
means and like I find that overwhelming
and like anxiety and juicing rather than
appealing
but otherwise I think I'm really excited
so we got 45 minutes of the Starfield
direct here expectations I don't even
really know I'd love to see all the
races so far we've only seen humans and
I feel like that's so boring in a space
game so give me
weird looking aliens please would love
to see more of the combat
um
and I guess yeah I want an understanding
of what we're going to be doing on these
thousand planets and certainly even
though I know they touched on it before
and it's like almost a given with
Bethesda at this point
mod support is the thing I'm really
interested in because I feel like you
could have modders
like just create all the content for
those thousand planets and then it
wouldn't be a problem so that's super
exciting um
yeah I was talking to Todd Howard a
little bit last night actually
uh
about how long he's been working in the
industry and just super interesting like
how some people are just such Staples
you know it's it's nuts
um okay without further ado
let's watch the Starfield direct
everybody let me you know if the audio
levels are okay
brilliant
okay great there we go
I'm covering uh countdown timer
everybody
five four three two one
we shouldn't be loading this has been
sitting here for so long come on my
internet's been such a butt today
okay
[Music]
I gotta pause it for a second I just
gotta let it let it load for a little
bit this never happens but my incident
has been such an [__] today so
we'll just give it a second sorry
everybody
it's qualied on auto no actually and I
guess that would oh it is on auto
yeah
but like
it's not on 4K I left this
um
when I went out today
maybe I should refresh it's 10508 okay
oh no 508 oh my God stupid internet
okay let's try that again
here's fine
is this this is
a very hype
joining us today and welcome to Bethesda
game studios you know we've been so
lucky over the decades to make the kind
of games that we love here and that's
thanks to all of you from the Elder
Scrolls The Fallout we love creating
these worlds and playing in them just as
much as you do and throughout all that
time
up the space game what if we could take
that feeling of being who you want to be
and exploring a new world but set it in
space where you weren't really Limited
in where you could go or what you could
do and that is Starfield obviously we've
come a long way since then with the
games we've built our technology and all
of us here in the studio we've done so
much together but well we've never tried
to make a game like this today you'll
get to hear from many on the team and
see so much of what we think makes our
game special so let's jump in and take a
look thanks Todd I would love to I would
love to
[Music]
Starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years but it's still a Bethesda
RPG through and through where you step
into a new world and you get that
feeling of unlimited possibilities
but this time loving the UI not just one
world there's just a little health bar
underneath my webcam by the way
it's over a thousand worlds okay again
that's scary of where to go it's not
ours it's yours
and we've heard it with no man's sky and
it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
beautiful to the people and creatures
that live in these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
whoa we realistically simulate the
Galaxy around you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of story and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
cool
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
you know I think I will
I want to do third person to be honest
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale it looks so much like no
man's sky so far exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
I wonder if they have any concerns oh my
God I honestly I said this earlier today
the combat
I feel like looks like a massive
massive energy
saying I wonder if they have any
concerns about all of the items allowing
you to pick everything up
in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
to spacesuits
two food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left vosco here back I'm a big fan
welcome back
and he can even say your name let's head
out
my name whose name everybody's names
how it's pretty basic Todd Howard must
convey the Wonder and Majesty of space
exploration to evoke the Romance of the
golden age of early space flight and
we've been referring to this approach as
NASA Punk this means a design language
where the tech is advanced yet still
looks grounded and relatable for us it's
a contrast that's where the visual
interest is obviously the NASA which is
the rigid pod function over style and
then Punk which is all about Style
visual style coming through in your ship
your ship is your home for you and your
crew and because many of the spaces in
our game it has a slightly retro and
analog touch a bit of Lo-Fi rather than
sci-fi I feel like they nailed
everything is well used mourn and lived
in NASA look alrighty what's the plan
captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its Infamous music is
like you can choose a landing spot or
fast travel to killing the the Epic
reveal of the scale first game you can
view all the planets in the system
obviously the game is big and it's here
you can see planets that have key
locations missions or life on them
versus the many planets that are Barren
but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems
here you can plot a course to ones that
are light years away this uses your
ship's grab drive to fold space and jump
to these systems and you will need to
upgrade your shipping skills if you want
to jump to the most distant ones but for
now we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
[Music]
so that
is a little less no man's sky
you are still going into land
complete you are cleared for landing at
new Atlantis
oh no okay so it's like Auto Landing
like
not like no man's sky
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings
[Music]
but also in the amount of custom art
crowds the lighting is
the Best Buy focus when we're designing
a city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day it's paralyzed if you
really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
thank you
[Music]
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about by the time you meet them
constellation is sort of seen as this
mythical group most people don't even
know that's a cool shot William they're
the last the cool shirts in the galaxy
and they're trying to find the answers
to some of Humanity's biggest questions
the
I'm so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God look at how it's coming
together that means there's a set built
by an intelligence outside the settled
systems it's definitely a bit of a way
to cast interaction but I wonder if that
was just the trailer the ex-soldier and
adventurer now constellations leader
Mateo the Theologian who believes that
there's definitely something else out
there Noel the gifted faces obviously
Morgan's Protege photo realistic but
they look better
man and the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money I can't
wait for him
the former Space Cowboy and Barrett you
know what I hate about these Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm nice the journey with
constellation is just the first of many
you'll embark on the settled systems is
home to all kinds of different stories
people and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is very impressed by
these environments the first major human
settlement also you know what's like if
this is a weird thing to say
I'm sure people are going to get upset
with me for this
I am excited
for the initial funny Bethesda pugs okay
I think there's something really funny
and Charming about them okay
I already look forward to seeing them
I don't know if I'm allowed to say that
he's obviously bugs are bad we don't
want games with bugs
I'm looking forward to it
thank you
like it being in a Sci-Fi game too
I don't know
I also think the Jank is charming with a
game this big how could they possibly QA
it you know
that's all I'm saying
people who live here value law
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves exactly so much
company potential the gravity of bugs
it's gonna be great if you get your UC
citizenship
new Atlantis isn't the only city within
the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
there is always like a really nice in a
Thursday game too that I feel like maybe
not this is Freestar Collective space
capital of the freestyle Collective this
is
[Music]
Stone root Inn is in Aquila City fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
God damn neon started out all right
almost anything goes if you've got
morality issues this definitely isn't
the job for you
dude
I love them
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed all right
I think that face
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy
stairs they are wrong it belongs to the
Crimson Fleet it always has
[Music]
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
this is kind of incomprehensible it's
all there waiting for you a slice of
Humanity's future
like I just want to try it man ready to
get out
there throughout the Galaxy there are so
many things to see and stories to
experience
a story is the one that you tell
the type of person hours in character
creation and I think people are going to
be really excited when they see all of
the improvements we've made I do love a
good character created my friends
overhauls was done through our character
generation system we scanned a wide
range of faces from different age groups
and ethnicities and by mixing and
matching all that data we were able to
create a highly detailed and diverse
characters we use that exact system to
create all the characters and NPCs
you're going to see in the game so any
character you see almost always is a
character you could make yourself that's
cool I mean uh a lot of more games do do
that cyberpunk did that hey so you can
walk around with my hairstyle okay take
it easy you were out cold uh no physical
damage mentally the jury still agreed
it's a bummy you can't be alien you know
who you are new recruit for Argos
extractors bring any bells
any of this look familiar
maybe they'll reveal others you start
your character creation Journey as
though you're cycling through employee
records you'll pick from a lineup of 40
presets and that'll be your starting
point
Journey from there can be as cool
for
[Music]
it's also the simplest character
generation it does look a lot better
than everything as close as possible to
make whatever they want with the various
facial morphs you can blend together the
thermostatic and makeup blemishes scars
piercings teeth settings it's a lot but
I think it's the most fun to use no
[Applause]
you put those chompas away who you want
to be that's where ain't nobody else
gonna see those all right he went
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills from Chef to Dusty you know the
crew still has a bedding pool about
which restaurant critic you must have
crossed to wind up here what's great
about backgrounds is you never know when
yours is going to come in handy you
could be in the middle of a fancy
restaurant
and suddenly you learn you need to be
something and I guess to help track down
a monster fine everything's gonna have a
stick to professionals anyway like the
day night was gonna be different on
different planets which is cool we're
also giving you the option to customize
your build even further by letting you
pick up the three traits traits are
completely optional and they come with
their own advantages and disadvantages
you could choose so meet your biggest
fan
is it really really you no Jordan I
don't need anything gifts if you're
willing to put up with this constant
commentary I can't believe I get to
stand near you breathing the same air
I've got to have every molecule my
favorite trait is kid stuff you have to
pay some credits to support your parents
but they're very sweet and it's really
fun to go visit them honey we got
ourselves a visitor oh my God I came
across some hostile zealots in space but
because I had chosen a treat that made
me the same religion as them I was able
to get by without any issues
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buff when your health is low
but mercenaries will randomly show up
and try to kill you
no matter what you choose plenty of ways
kid stuff is super interesting your
story you just let me have like a mom
and dad simulator no ways to do that too
what a view It's A Feast for the eyes
off we go dude
no let you discover that on your own
thank you
[Music]
this is really well produced this is
really a really well made piece once
you've built the perfect character whoa
[__] bro
you took what we loved about skills like
that
put them together to create an all-new
skill system
each time you level up you get a skill
point right which can be used to unlock
or rank up skills looks nice
I like the um ranks are unlocked by
completing challenge
become increasingly difficult as you
work your way to higher ranks
with our five different skill trees and
four ranks per skill there's a lot to
choose from
control aliens oh
they're there um they're patches
they look like they're hand-stitched
patches that's such a nice touch
yeah it's definitely more of an amazing
physical tree so I can get neuro strikes
and just punch my way through combat
some of that previous characters
that was a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
I'm very much a stealth player so I'm
out there pickpocketing everyone
my favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and swinging on
people
so cool to see whenever possible I like
to talk my way through situations series
off limits
fine I'll issue you an access card
Run and Gun player
I like doing the death from above thing
where I boost pack over guys and I throw
landmines at them
oh
[Music]
I'm gonna pay for that
I like blowing stuff up all I'm saying
is the combat be looking good I really
am
super impressed
like we went from Fallout where I
preferred using Vats because I did not
like
their attempted
gun oriented exploration action combat
key aspect of all our games this looks
good star field there are full star
systems and it does look different to
how it looks resources and Adventures
I wonder if they had other teams help
them at the moment our team worked hard
to strike a balance between fun and
realism we studied data from NASA and a
multitude of other sources to help us
make the world feel believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships like I feel
like obviously again no man's Sky it's
the obvious comparison
I saw people be like they're not even
similar those people are insane they're
similar people are going to draw
comparisons it's a no-brainer ultimately
it's about rewarding your curiosity but
before these two games
of the city or the vastness of space you
never know what you'll find
wait so I still don't understand
are they Landing animation possible
thanks to your ship your ship is almost
like having another character or home
you can make all your own and it'll be
like baseball
type stuff you'll just do it on your
ship and buy a ship I'm sure you can
find something you like customize and
upgrade that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
options it all starts in spaceports
I have so many questions dude
technician where you can purchase sell
and modify ships anything I can help you
with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space braider to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling for now though we're going to
take our starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields
or you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems
can give you more room for crew
adding cowling can change your ship's
overall silhouette
an improved grav Drive allows for longer
distance space jobs
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you I was
going to ask but they're answering it
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
oh money is an in-game ship
manufacturers bring their own look and
feel to every piece of your ship God
to cargo holds so I guess like are you
walking to get your ship to be better is
that like going to be a big through line
here
we still don't know that much about the
narrative like I mean we know that's our
modified Frontier big company but with a
little creativity you're pirating can
look like almost anything you want
time to penis but one of my favorite
ways of customizing how long is it going
to take somebody to build a deck
I make them look like animals
the HMS platypus as I called it
[Music]
like a giant tail to it that's really
cute and we've done spiders we've done
mixed they look like mix so it's really
whoa
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars oh my god dude you're probably
not the only person who will call your
ship home
[Music]
yeah so crew you could I could just use
the whole presentation about the ship
stuff
engines ready
Frontier is fueled and ready captain
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together that's cool
find an artifact or this lead runs dry I
have people you love can we romance each
companion comes with their own valuable
skills for your ships and outposts
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships
I don't know that I've ever really loved
anyone
except you confirm if you're looking for
a little extra on your ship you can
always hire additional crew at
spaceports got any room on your ship for
someone like me this is neat
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assigned crew to your ship or outposts
and their unique skills will affect how
they run
yeah a lot of like really immersive Sim
and just gameplay companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance I love him he's
designed around the core basics of a
NASA machine please avoid getting shot
you might die
with almost a humanoid personality so I
elongated the limbs this tends to make
him feel more human-like and give him a
little personality it is a shame
exploration requires so much you did
just kind of say the same thing twice I
wanted to give him using the ship
building tools and personalities
ship of your dreams
but can I [__] the robot
and now let's take to the sky
hey I'm
damn dude
but that's like that's a cine right and
then
you I assume that's a city that's it's
got to be a load extreme
and then you just get
like gameplay is in space and then it
loads like how else could that even
affect very own spaceship they're
telling you that you can do pretty much
which I'm not mad about totally fine as
developers thank you
flight should be exciting and dangerous
and you should feel like you're in
complete control every step of the way
what about just hitting your triggers to
fire your weapons
it's a complex dance between your
piloting skills and our power allocation
system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
powering up the ground dries will
shorten the amount of time it takes
before you can make a jump
it is a loading screen I mean again I
expected it would have been which one is
it and moving your power to your weapons
and shields means you're ready for a
fight
cool very uh Star Wars squadrons I
should always be on your toes because
you're not alone out there yeah I have
played uh both stuffed as an end no
man's Sky I feel it for all I just
wasn't sure about in this case
I mean I love no man's Sky now
unlocking the targeting control system
skill will allow you this I feel like
this is underrated this little stitches
you target
Style
so I wonder if players who aren't
interested in the Space Battles can just
avoid them destroying an enemy ship you
can loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap that's how you
got to build your ships right
but I wonder if we don't want to do that
stuff can we just not do that by docking
with the Enemy vessel and boarding their
ship
what
to any of them
that's so cool of an enemy ship it's
yours
and retrieve it at any Spaceport
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
there are plenty of sights to see and
stops to make on the way to your next I
wonder how often people try to board you
oh my God
this game is too big
Walk The Halls talk to the crew maybe
get talked into buying a whole new ship
a civilian in my style yard let's see
about getting you a proper ship one
worthy of you kiwi maybe you'll dock
with a gigantic Battleship like the UC
vigilance
or rub elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy
Elite on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
that's neat there are plenty I imagine
you can't steal cruise ships you can
tell any ship you come across sure swap
info or maybe even commit an act of
piracy let's do this when I'm playing I
generally go crazy
um I definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to board ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
you know in my cargo hold that I have
specifically for sandwiches a lot of
Sandwich content from Xbox today and
just start taking things from people as
quickly as possible
some strangers might be looking for a
little human Connection in the darkness
of space
[Music]
I just finished cooking
some of the best moments are the ones
you discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through it's really about going to
strange new places meeting interesting
people and getting sidetracked on zany
Adventures then realizing two hours
later that you're involved in a
completely new story you'll
we thought we were the only ones to
leave Earth that DNA is so present here
that's just random encounters it's in
our handcrafted quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you is that too
many
I don't know
we want you to feel like explorers
breaking ground on new planets exploring
every inch Galaxy
[Music]
we want you to feel hopeful we want you
to feel the sense of awe and wonder
and sometimes a little fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
I'm I feel slightly overwhelmed
banjo you can't just steal stuff from
the trash bud
hey everybody we've shown you so much
stuff but we thought we'd just take a
little break and show you something a
little bit different get your own toys
and try to listen to taught how we talk
about stop being worlds and we love the
opportunity to bring that into the real
world with our Collector's Editions and
for this game uh we've done a watch I
actually already constellation
Explorer's watch I already did this is
the watch that you actually get in the
game that acts as part of your HUD where
it's the compass and then environmental
information it connects to your phone
Bethesda store and other information and
we've also designed this really cool
case that it comes with eastvan
yeah we really took as much care and
designed as cases we did the watch that
was the last place
used during the Apollo era to bring back
samples from the Moon oh that's so cool
walking mechanism authentic heavy comes
with a constellation patch native strap
and the overall functionality and
believability of this as something that
would exist in the world in the
Starfield Universe
started getting more collect positions
with the intention of giving them away
now that we're part of Xbox we get to
work with the amazing people on the Xbox
Hardware team and together we have
created this custom limited edition
Starfield controller it's awesome it is
now you know our favorite controller we
love this because it's inspired by the
actual controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox that's a great idea
this is a perfect pairing with that
controller
where's the console
I want a white series X damn it
come on
very cool though I do love it
I'm not a controller collector there's
too many of them
new headset custom is a really neat idea
especially for a game like this
I want a wide series X so bad honestly
like I'm upset
or a popular blue but just anything
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big this is like a very
calming presentation freedom on a
galactic level like the people speaking
in like a freedom to experience both
exciting planets
the music Quiet Ones
like I feel very cute I'll plan it
before you land is a great way to get a
sneak peek at the available resources
you can use for crafting building and
customizing I think what's cool about
this whole system that we we generate
the planet itself as a procedural
content but the handcrafted content
itself comes as the player explore
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together the
lack of terrain interesting after that
we have the system that adds interested
Communications for the player to explore
creatures to encounter
yeah so but we've still only seen
hostile
it allows us very Touch of surely part
of the retailing that's what it that's
what this is known for
aggressive creatures have been
disrupting our experiments their habitat
isn't far from here loving the accent of
them for us we would be in your debt so
even if your friends were to visit the
same planet that you had you would have
a different story to tell
I don't know if I like that to be honest
but I guess with the scale of it you
kind of have to otherwise I'm just
kidding
Doug
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
or simply take in the views
with the help of yourself
and discover exotic wildlife
have the skills you can even figure out
that certain creatures and plants you
can build an outpost and produce
resources from those plants and animals
you can get experience and rewards for
fully surveying planets and fully
surveying a whole system
[Music]
when we were concepting these creatures
we really wanted to think of them as
natural to the environment we didn't
want alien monsters we want a native
wildlife
something you've never seen before I
mean most of them are scary to be honest
most of these looked terrified
which I'm all right comes to our but yes
very no man's Sky
all that light is calculated in real
time through the atmosphere that's sick
our biggest goal for lighting with
Starfield was to make the game feel more
filmic
and color to really make it feel more
cinematic yeah they got some ugly games
to be honest
[Music]
cinematic I feel like suits A Space
Adventure that makes sense
[Music]
what a shot
after some exploring you can find a spot
to set up a base camp
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any planet and the habitat modules come
in all shapes and sizes filling all
different purposes you can even live in
them assign crew and companions to work
at your outposts for added bonuses and
set up extractors to harvest resources
while you're away
something cool we have this time is we
have a new flycam where you can toggle
between on foot building or you can now
use a top-down isometric camera right
they mentioned basically before right
no man's sky that way you can really
plan which is like the overall feel of
your Outpost is like honestly you can
really decorate and find so much time so
much easier God
is this too much video game
is there maybe too much video game in
the video game
this looks amazing
[Music]
I'm like what about this and they're
like here you go I'm like damn dude
wow and research stations in your
Outpost to utilize any resources you
find or already have
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sights and
Scopes larger magazines I'll selection
this isn't a single player game
different ammunition like Explosive
Rounds crazy
I like yes it is like no man's Skyrim
there will surely cool with it I'm all
right with no man's Skyrim
you can also choose to go Hands-On with
melee weapons
I mean like what's realistic what's Sim
and what's Hollywood and I think we sort
of err on the side of like what's fun
for the player
with Starfield we've completely
overhauled our combat yeah it's more
Dynamic the animations are more fluid
it just feels great it's so much better
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than I want to say
any other game we've done before
a lot of variety I hopes
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
Edge in combat
so
six minutes
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
cooking experience
and they also have mag weapons
these are high-powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
that's cool
get up close and personal with your own
two fists or you like more comments wow
animation looks much better or maybe you
prefer something bigger
yeah nice very full out pull out I
prefer to Elder Scrolls personally got
you covered
um so the similarities there I'm totally
happy with
combat
if you like that combat previously has
been
soda bad
or at least a little bit behind
this
this is probably the first one I've
wanted to play but there's the game for
the combat
as well as everything else yeah I also
still really like Elder Scrolls uh just
prefer so let's tell you I do
yeah is there still a bat system
because I mean that shouldn't be but you
couldn't recite my game
[Music]
because this is also really
differentiating it from Outer worlds
I mean in a bunch of ways it's doing a
lot more than out at once
which makes me curious about how adults
too will be but I really liked that game
as well
I'm saying outer Worlds by the way not
Wilds
two different games
what
thanks again what was that with us today
we are just so grateful that you've
taken the time and spent it here I know
there was magic as well and there's a
lot to the game even more than we could
show here you know as we play it we're
always sharing these unique and special
moments that only a game like this can
bring when I think about what makes it
special it really is the people here
this game is a reflection of the
incredible and passionate team that made
it all of them putting something special
of themselves into it so let's hear some
of their favorite moments
this is a really good presentation the
way that our final love including more
in the dead teams
the most beautiful sunsets and sunrises
we've ever had in many of our games also
the thing I like the most so far is the
exploration every biome is different the
word that comes to mind is vast yeah I
like to use our photo mode to take
Rockstar photos
I just love that constant feel of
Discovery and wow I can't believe that
there's more here I'm most excited about
our Outpost Building Systems
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
you spent all this time building your
ship and you see it on the landing pad
these things are gigantic it's the kind
of thing that you just can't get
anywhere else there's something about
seeing a tower over in the distance and
going I know the gravity's low here I
think I can make that jump that's
awesome biomes spaceships audio design
planets the day night cycle those
details matter to me diplomacy
exploration Freedom the ending basket
obviously I love the robot so much the
incredible amount of Worlds we created
sniper rifles come on lever action
rocket launcher brain sprout
I love but some people might find creepy
the thing that I enjoy most about the
game is the freedom to be who you want
what do what you want to do
it's what you've come to expect from a
Bethesda title but on a much bigger
scale
so I wonder if we'll get Space Powers as
we put the Halos together
on behalf of all of us alien Tech we
can't wait for you and it's a big part
of the story we'll be about finding out
your own special moments
God damn dude
how about population
[Music]
this is unbelievable
uh okay
yeah okay great
I always have to think about the dates
um
I don't know what's left
okay it's just gonna be like a little
recap
um
so
obviously
can't really say without playing it this
is still a piece of marketing right
um really hard to say without getting
our hands on it but
I feel like I came into this with high
expectations and they just kept giving
me more information that I didn't expect
that I really like
like this is a very very good Showcase
in my opinion I'm sure there are people
on the internet [__] all over it
um
because
it's the internet but
I was like here are some things I'm
curious about and I still have some of
those which is good
here are uh things I'm hopeful for and
then they just gave me
more things than I even cared about that
I like
this it this was a
very good showcase like exceeded
at least for me personally because it's
Bethesda
um softworks
extremely high expectations
God damn
and I also just want to give them a
shout out for this presentation I love
having
the sit-downs with devs from different
departments who are all really good on
camera by the way which can kind of be
really hard to find
um
everyone talking about the different
vocation
the pacing
the humanity behind it like
I just
feel like like this is probably one of
like the best
single video game features
maybe ever like damn dude
this is very very very good
um
super excited to play the game this year
kind of afraid
I still think that
I don't know how I'm gonna play it yet
right like the
however many thousand planets still
doesn't appeal to me very much
um
so maybe I won't do that much
exploration versus other people I don't
know and it's like a lot of games I'm
like okay here's this thing I'm
interested in but I don't know if this
game is going to be for me am I going to
play the whole thing or am I just gonna
try it out and
not fall in love with it um it feels
like there are so many options here
and yeah I also agree that I think the
combat I didn't think it looked
horrendous last time but I feel like the
combat got improved
versus how it looked in the last
presentation
damn I'm definitely not very interested
in space combat but the
the ship docking thing dude
oh my God
wow
um yeah I'm blown away but do you want
to see aliens I'm hoping they're holding
that for the story which I get
um we know that Bethesda knows how to
make different races
it's the Elder Scrolls obviously they
know how to do that
um
I'm guessing that's being held back and
I get why so you don't know what they
look like yet
the sound too oh
yeah Blown Away wow damn